c'est sans doute le début d'une nouvelle
ère de la médecine la thérapie génique
en action une équipe américaine a réussi
dans une première expérience prometteuse
à traiter un malade du coeur en
réussissant à faire repousser les
artères coronariennes qui apporte le
sens au coeur jusqu'à présent les seules
techniques existantes étaient les
pontages jean daniel flaysakier bernard
puis ce sens un équipement lourd des
chirurgiens des anesthésistes très
expérimentée il faut tout cela pour
remplacer les quelques centimètres d'une
artère du coeur quand l'artère coronaire
est obstruée par une plaque de
cholestérol on va en effet faire ce que
l'on appelle un pontage en branchant
directement sur l'aorte une veine qui va
amener le sens aux muscles du coeur au
delà de la zone obstruée
et bientôt pour réparer ses artères
bouchées on aura peut-être plus besoin
systématiquement sur d'opérer à coeur
ouvert une équipe américaine vient en
effet pour la première fois de faire ce
qu'on appelle un essai de thérapie
génique le principe faire déposer par un
virus un gène dans la paroi des artères
se gênent va commander la fabrication de
nouveaux vaisseaux un pontage naturel en
quelque sorte où les tous premiers
essais qui ont été effectuées chez
l'animal ont montré qu'il y avait eu une
amélioration de la qualité du tissu
cardiaque après la formation de nouveaux
vaisseaux
pour autant le comptage traditionnel ne
disparaîtra pas on travaille même
actuellement des techniques de thérapie
génique pour empêcher les veines greffés
de se boucher à leur tour